[Musique]
coville 19 oblige on observe depuis
quelques semaines l'apparition de
nouveaux types de danse en ligne les
parties de dj sur internet
[Musique]
sur les réseaux sociaux des dj
internationaux comme bob sinclar attire
plus de 2 millions d'internautes à
chacune de leur diffusion en direct
[Musique]
de berlin à ibiza en quelques clics les
oiseaux de nuit peuvent se téléporter
dans les grands clubs et les dj d'ici
aussi sont au rendez vous l'organisme
montréal 24 24 en collaboration avec
drake la studio présente depuis quatre
semaines les événements transmission une
manière pour recréer l'ambiance les
organisateurs utilisent des 400 de
vidéoconférence et les transforme en
boîte de nuit virtuel les gens se
déguise des gens dans la folie et en os
[Musique]
et même si un son virtuel
ces rencontres et les échanges
artistiques ne reste pas moins bien réel
chacun chez soi disque j'étais et vidéos
de jeux qui partagent le même écran
je savais pas avant c'est sûr que je
préfère la vraie vie je les clubs les
cons système de son l'énergie mais c'est
peut-être d autres choses qu'on va
apprendre que plus tard va devenir
partie de toutes nos activités à la
société des arts technologiques ou si on
estime que les performances en ligne
sont là pour rester
même lorsque nous serons des confiner le
streaming le héros diffusion en live de
plus en plus présente à la saturn en
réflexion pour créer un plateau de
captation on pense que ça va être
quelque chose qui va rester
complémentaires maman alors qu'on peut
avoir en réel
en attendant ces soirées virtuels sont
une invitation à bouger et à transformer
vos salons en prester de danse
ils signent alexandre chartier
radio-canada pour